[inaudible]
uh,
when I was planning this book,
I thought if I wrote a
book titled Something like,
Why Einstein is smarter than us
and we're a bunch of dumb schmucks,
we're not very interested
in buying a book like that.
But if there is a book about poor Einstein
had these terrible problems and we
can feel superior console him,
that's really good.
You feel that's a pretty good day.
I'm,
I'm helping my poor little friend
Einstein. Everyone's interested in him.
I'm assuming many.
Most of us here know some of what he did.
Just to remind her aside from
minor things, put it this way,
the theory of relativity and
equals mc squared was so small.
That was just the beginning of his,
that he was so good.
He had two theories of relativity.
So one in 1905 when he was 26.
Those of you who are approaching 26 feel
anxious, you have like a count down to,
uh, to getting there.
If it's any consolation,
you can feel even more
anxious if you're younger.
There was a fellow I studied with at the
University of Chicago when I was young
and he was old. And at one point, uh,
this fellow was on a boat going from
India to England. And he said, oh, sorry,
it's been so many years that I'd
been striving and I'm such a failure.
I've accomplished nothing. This is
awful. His name was Chandra say car.
The Shaundra ex-ray satellite is named
after him and he was 19 years old.
And in the midst of his despair,
he came up with basically
the idea of black holes,
which is pretty impressive in the 1930s.
Anyway,
so Einstein of 25 did great stuff, special
relativity. At 35, he did greater stuff.
General relativity. If
Einstein, if nobody, if he
hadn't done special relativity,
uh, Poincare Lorenz, lots
of people have done it.
If he hadn't done general relativity,
we would still be waiting for it.
Think about that in your field.
How many things,
if a particular organization disappears,
would not get done by anybody else?
That's really rare and really special.
He was very good.
He wasn't just good in um, uh, in,
in science as you might imagine.
He was incredibly good in
practical technology. Uh,
wouldn't if it's great inventions that
he was really proud of and spent a lot of
time on in the 1920s was the refrigerator,
new improved refrigerators,
refrigerators in Berlin leaked all
the time and he didn't want leaky
refrigerators so he produced a wonderful
non leaky refrigerator. There's a,
a letter to his great friend mocks born,
um,
who also a Nobel laureate and you
wonder what Nobel laureates discuss.
My refrigerator barely leaks. The new
prototype is even better than last time.
Next time down to 3.6% leak.
Yes.
Einstein was very excited in 1916 he
needed to take a break when weekend and he
was thinking not about refrigerators
and not about general relativity and
casually he came up with the
key idea behind the laser,
which is pretty impressive.
The first practical ones,
I think masers first microwaves were
only built 40 years later. Um, uh,
this organization would not work very
well if there weren't lasers zipping round
through a fiber optics and stuff.
He also came up with the um, uh,
the photoelectric effect. If you
think about it, there's light,
which is kind of energy and
there's electrons which are
in substance and we take
for granted, Oh yeah. You know,
light metals makes things happen.
We use it in our phone cameras all the
time. How does that possibly happen?
How does light, which is energy, how
does that, how does that make stuff move?
It's really impressive.
So he came up with that in 1905.
That wasn't even his greatest
work. Anyways, he was terrific,
but then the secret is greatest mistake.
It turned out he made a mistake,
a psychological mistake, and it
was catastrophic. And it led,
even though he was world famous and his
mind was still delayed in his forties
and stuff, and people exactly his
age were staying on with good work.
He became shunned.
He was the laughingstock in the physics
community when he was at Princeton.
He was at a, what outsiders called the
Princeton Institute for Advanced Studies.
Insiders called it the Princeton
Institute for advanced salaries.
They had a lot of money to bring a good
refugee scientists over and for 30 years
there are people would say,
Ooh, don't go near him.
It's going to destroy your career. Ooh,
don't go near him. He's a husband. He's a,
he's an archaic nothing.
And it really hurt his feelings because
when he was young and trendy before the,
the hair thing and stuff, he was on top
of the world. Everybody came to him.
Einstein once said that people think in
two different ways. Um, uh, quiet quiz.
You can see which one is you. He said
they're either tennis players or golfers,
tennis players. They just need
ideas back and forth. Uh, you,
you only clarify it when you talk with
other people. Golfers are the ones who,
you know, often the neighbors when
they're interviewed by the police,
that he seems such a quiet and nice
young man of the golfers are the ones who
need to sit quietly and think and
cogitate and don't disturb me.
They go to find a little corner in a cafe.
And with that they come
up with great ideas. Well,
it turns out Einstein was actually
a tennis player. He, he, uh, he,
he wasn't a golfer in that respect.
And to be isolated from other people,
to have nobody come to his office and not
have bright Grad students want to work
with him, that was awful, awful. So
it turns out how did this happen?
Why did this terrible thing happened?
And there's a curious a parallel with high
tech. So I'll start talking about, um,
some, how you see this on a large
scale, like a sort of a large display.
And then we'll zoom back in. We'll take
a microscope insight Einstein's brain.
So we'll zoom out now a little bit and
I want to talk about an organization
which some of you,
most of many of you will have heard of.
And some of you may have studied
at the Cavendish lab in Cambridge.
The Cavendish lab is about, uh,
in the 19, early 1920, sorry,
in the early 19 hundreds,
the Cavendish lab was around the
size of the floor of this building,
a little bit smaller than
the floor of this building.
It produced in a 20 year period more
Nobel Prize winners than all of France,
all of Japan,
all of Italy have ever done combined.
And those are countries with
terrific educational backgrounds.
Think how could a place about
half the size of this floor,
maybe with some spill out labs
of the size of this floor,
do something like that that's
above and beyond anything else.
And it wasn't just patronage,
it wasn't that they were rigged on the
Nobel Committee. This was stunning work.
The foundations of the modern world,
modern science,
and it turns out there were
several things they did.
A one thing was kind of small. At 6:00
PM they turned off the electricity.
You could sit there but you were in
the dark. It means you had to focus.
You know sometimes if you have to
give her presentation, it clears head.
If you have to give a presentation with
20 minutes prep, it's not too good.
But if you have half a day
rather than three weeks,
you'll really focus in that half day.
6:00 PM electricity was really good.
They also help with
diseases. Very, very useful.
But there are two things they did there
were even better at the Cavendish lab
and these later feedback you'll see
them taking place in Einstein's mind.
One is that they made their
own tools. Uh, a long time ago,
a an Air France used to have microphones
in the first class seats from San
Francisco to La to Paris.
They thought they would listen in the
French government under Mitra wrong.
They would listen to it. I'm a secrets of
Silicon Valley and copy it immediately.
That's depressing.
Saying here's other guys who are terrific.
Let's see if we can catch up with them.
Much better is to make your own tools
and be first see who catches up with you.
There was a young guy working
at this Cavendish lab from
Germany, a Grad student.
He thought we need a better way to
detect little bits of radiation.
His name was Hans Geiger.
Thus the hands counter, no,
the Geiger counter a named in his honor.
They had lots of tools like that.
It was this wonderful confidence that
was good. So 6:00 PM stops was good.
Making your own tools as good,
but the best of all is the guy
who ran it was a New Zealand,
a farmer named Rutherford.
Um,
and he had a concept of what I
call a mid level abstraction.
If you tell somebody coming to a
research lab, let's be the best.
It doesn't really help you. I
mean, it applies to Nike shoes.
It doesn't give you anything help.
If you say to somebody coming
to a great research lab,
give them some very detailed thing.
Phillips needs help and Jut calibrating
this microscope and we're doing an
interesting piece of work there.
That's fine.
It's great to help Phillips and you
can be really good at microscopes,
but that's one one thing, it's too
detailed. Uh, would rather for data.
The Cavendish lab in the 19
teens in 1920s come up with what,
what is a mid level abstraction?
He had one guiding principle,
which wasn't too abstract and
wasn't too particular. He said,
everybody who came to the lab,
you know what we're going to do,
we're going to find out what's inside the
atom. Nothing more, nothing left less.
It's a perfect idea. With that.
Everybody understands what's going on.
Everybody can share,
but you're not telling them what to do.
You give them a real lot of freedom,
but they're still pulling together a
San Exupery, the French poet once said,
love isn't looking into each other's eyes.
It's looking together
in the same direction.
If you've ever been in a poisonous
organization where people are pulling in
different directions, you don't quite
understand what's going on. You don't.
People don't understand why they
should work with each other.
You'll know how important that was.
Mid level abstraction was wonderful.
Second question. So that's how how
you create a great, uh, organization.
In this case, the greatest research lab
the world has ever seen. Second question,
how do they stay that way?
And the answer is they usually don't.
They almost always fade.
Within about 20 years,
the Cavendish lab under a
Rutherford was magnificent.
Then after about the mid 1920s,
it faded away.
That approach different didn't work.
The outside world was changing how
to find what's inside the atom.
With tools you can make yourself
in Cambridge, it stopped.
It was really a upsetting.
So now occasionally companies can keep
on doing the same thing for a real long
time. I worked for awhile
with a shell scenarios.
Shell has a very simple principle.
It's not abstract be the best.
It's not incredibly detailed. Do this one
arrangement with rock. It's extract oil,
using really good engineers
and make clever political
arrangements with your, uh,
with the companies that supply it. It's
worked well for 120 years. So that's,
that's fine. That's a simple, unchanging
field. If they can get into clean energy,
well I'd be surprised, pleasantly
surprised, but surprised. So,
but that's their obstruction. Usually
that doesn't work. So Einstein's life,
if we go back to him now,
he sort of solves the problem about how
you can do better than these companies
and he also reveals a possible answer.
So like I said,
it's going to give a little microscope
going inside his brain. So, uh,
I'll talk a bit about his creativity and
his creativity was very much like those
big companies. So the companies, one
thing they did was the thing, you know,
pulling the plug at 6:00
PM from electricity.
Einstein didn't have a limitation with
electricity. They often say, you know,
you can do, um, uh, mathematics
and theoretical physics,
which just the pencil paper and a,
and a dustbin, a waste, a waste,
a wastebasket of,
they also cynics will say,
you can do philosophy and secondly the
same way, but you don't need the dustbin,
which is kind of cruel. Einstein
himself, loved good philosophers.
A client at one point had an image of
spacetime diagrams, which is really good.
And the 17,
seven days Hume's notions about causality
and just looking at what you observe,
where they're trying to understand
what's going on inside. These are great,
powerful notions. So Einstein, the
equivalent of the 6:00 PM stop.
He had terrible problems
and relationships.
His best friend after his best friend
died when they were both old men. Uh,
Einstein wrote to the best friend's
family, Mikayla base, I would said,
I admired your dad from being a
nice guy and a sounding board.
But what I admired best was that he made
a relationship with one woman work for
his entire life. Something which I sadly
have failed in twice. So a Einstein had,
has spent a lot of time moving from
apartment to apartment flat to flat,
escaping from one person having an affair.
Oh,
with the wrong person going off to another
one. It really restricted as time. Uh,
sometimes he was writing in a, in trains
cause he couldn't stay in any city.
So he had, he had, he had constraints
on his time for his tools,
developing your own tools. Uh, he
developed what's now kind of standard. He,
he really developed a tensors,
uh, those of you who aren't, uh,
with a technical background,
scalers are like,
like numbers and stuff and vectors or
like a number with a direction like an
arrow. And, um, and tensors just
generalize that a little bit more. Um,
it's in the appendix to the book.
Um,
so he developed that and he especially
developed an interesting ways of
understanding surfaces and stuff.
It was this own fresh tools,
which meant nobody else had it. Imagine
if you have a tool which nobody else has.
There was an athlete 40,
50 years ago who was a mid level jumper.
He wasn't incredible, but he found
a way. Dick Fosbury of jumping back,
I think it was Dick Fosbury was his
last night of jumping backwards.
This is the famous way that high jumpers
jump. Now, when he had that tool,
nobody else did. He was great. Even
though he wasn't a stunning athlete, uh,
once everybody else had it,
he had to fade away.
He wasn't that good
advantages to being first.
And then the other great thing
that Einstein was good at,
his mid level abstraction, that's a bit
technical. I get into it in the book.
It was a way of viewing how you can
view any physics problem independent of
whoever's watching,
whether I'm jumping up and down with
our moving quickly or slowly. How,
how would the world be? Look,
how would you think seem, if I,
if everybody's able to view things and
you can't tell 'em who has a prefer a
special position,
it's kind of very much a democracy.
I know it's kind of Waffley
to say it like that.
So I have to go leave the details in
the book. But he had his unique tools.
He had pressures on time and had
a beautiful mid level abstraction.
He wasn't trying to solve a
particular physics problems down here,
nor was he saying, I'm going to
be the best I'm going to achieve,
I'm going to create greatness. And his has
abstractions were very, very, very good.
Um,
anyways,
it turns out at one point he drew the
mechanism of how creativity happens inside
his own brain. And those of you
who read German as well as I do,
which is not too well, will not
be following the German. Uh,
what I'm going to do a while,
this slides up,
I'm going to draw something
like that roughly on the board.
So what Einstein said is down
here are things in the real world,
events and stuff that you look at.
And then we make a creative jump,
a creative leap of the imagination going
up here and from this vantage point we
see fresh things. We're, while
we're up here, I remember,
and this is a mid level thing, it's
not incredibly high. It isn't, oh,
I'm going to survey the world like a God,
but it's not a detail thing down here.
And from here you draw conclusions
and if the conclusions are right,
they match what's down there and then
this jump up has been correct. Right?
Very simple form that was, that
was this sort of forum. Um,
and that's what he said, how it works. And
from that perch you can see everything.
Anyways,
it's a great idea and I assign followed
it successfully for quite a few years,
but then after about 20 years has happened
so often, he stopped following it.
I have time to tell you a little bit of
the story about how he stopped following
it. The, the book is mostly about
that. It turns out in, um, a 19, 15,
19, 16, a hundred years ago in
the middle of wartime of Berlin,
he came up with an equation that describes
the entire shape of the universe. Um,
uh, as a rough example. And again,
apologies to people who've done it a
physics at a high level as a very rough
image. Imagine that space is like a
flat trampoline or a rubber sheet.
And if I take a little ball
bearing and flick it [inaudible],
it'll go in a straight line.
And if I flick it in some other way,
Those might be something like planets.
We just flick them along.
You see the big finger coming down over
from south of King's cross. Okay. Uh,
if you take a rock or a heavier ball
and put it in the middle of that sheet,
it'll sag down in that shape.
Right?
And think of that as like the sun or
something. Then if I flick a ball,
bearing the ball bearing instead
of going straight, well it will,
if it's far away,
if the sheets sagging down here,
the ball bearing will near very rounded
like in a billiards or pool table and
stuff. Kind of makes sense.
Again, it's only a metaphor here.
It's curving and space. In fact, in
reality it's curving in space time.
So wonderful notion. A force then
becomes just a distortion of space. Uh,
the geometry lead you along.
An example there is two people
walking to the North Pole.
You can start at different points on
the equator and you look at each other,
you're a few yards apart and you say,
we're going to stay parallel.
Where each going to go do north.
But you realize the geometry
will force you together.
You'll see this person coming closer
and closer to you. Say, oh wait,
you're not going straight hillside that
heck I am. I'm going perfectly straight.
So an intellectual what appears to be a
forest and come from a distortions of a
geometry that's a two dimensional
surface in our three dimensional space.
Space time is four dimensional,
four dimensional. So that's
how it works. Anyways,
the details are in the book.
That isn't what matters.
What matters is Einstein came out
of it with a beautiful equation.
G equals t geometry. Very
roughly. Geometry, uh,
creates how things move. And the, the,
the, this structure and shape of things,
which includes mass and energy will
shape the geometry around it. The, uh,
the fact of a heavy bowling boil will
sad the sheet of space time around it and
the curvature of space time will show
that there's gotta be something there.
You know, something they were behind it.
What a beautiful idea. Among other things.
Einstein worked out shortly afterwards
in 1917 was that this predicted that the
universe was expanding.
What an amazing idea.
And he went to his astronomer
for friends and said,
I've predicted the universe is expanding.
At least two simple equations that seem
to reveal the truth of the universe,
explaining the universe is expanding.
And as astronomer friends in 1917 said,
big mistake, the data shows the
opposite. The Universe is static.
The s the Milky Way galaxies is sitting
here kind of floating and beyond.
It is avoid sort of like
looking to Donald Trump's mind.
There's just nothing there.
Maybe some malicious entities and a
little bit of sneering coming back at us.
That's it. Um, so Einstein had to put
in a modification to his equation,
the famous lamb determ and instead of
this beautiful symmetry where he thought,
not so much that he detected the
hand of God, he was, he wasn't a,
he wasn't an atheist. He wasn't,
uh, a formal religious believer.
He was anti atheist. He said, how could
you be so sure? He was sort of in between,
kind of like Spinosa.
If you're interested in Pantheism,
it's quite extraordinary there.
They subtle structures there.
He didn't know why or what they came from.
He once gave an image of humans as being
like a little boy in a big library,
in a dark. It's at night.
There's myths, maybe foggy out.
And the the walls,
the library,
there's all these bookshelves around
with books and in those books are the
secrets of the universe.
They actually exist.
They've been specified really clearly.
Very occasionally the brightest members
of our species can walk forward,
go up to one of the books, open it,
and you'll actually see it at one line,
might say equals MC squared.
Wow.
Another might have the tensors
behind g equals t, um, and then, oh,
but then we usually have to close it,
go back and retreat.
But we know it's there waiting. Einstein
love that. Newton had seen some things.
Einstein had, was lucky enough to see some
things. Future generations could also,
it's a wonderful platonic dream.
Anyway,
so he felt bad that he had to modify that
simple gene equals t. But he said, okay,
if the data doesn't show that it's
correct, I'll have to modify it.
So he made us equation ugly for 10 years,
10 years later, a Hubble in California,
and other people said, boy, did we get
it wrong? Oh wait, did we get, are I,
I'm adding the oil? They probably
didn't say it like, um, and they said,
the universe is expanding. They found this
wonderful evidence, that room, you know,
it's expanding in each power
does expanding from the
other parts at a terrific
rate. And Einstein was so happy at that.
He said, I knew it. I knew it all along.
Have you ever, any of you here seen
galaxy quest? Uh, the film, uh,
you remember there,
there's this a boy,
a teenage boy hadn't earth who believes
that aliens are speaking to them and
stuff and nobody believes them and
stuff. He, he's, Oh yeah, I know.
It's just made up. And then he actually
hears, sees them this way. He said,
I knew it. I knew all along. It was
actually true. So that was Einstein.
After 10 years, he realized he
had to stick to his original.
He should have stuck to his
original thing. The experiment,
experimental evidence was agreed on
by all the astronomers in the world,
but they were wrong. If he had
just held his nerve a bit longer,
he would have been proven right.
How cool is that too simple forms
to simple tensors g equals t again,
I'm summarizing,
but basically that,
that somebody came up with in their
head in Berlin during World War One
predicted that and drop that our local
cluster is expanding away from other
parts of the galaxy.
How utterly extraordinary that advanced
primates can do something like that.
It was, it was wonderful.
Anyways, what conclusion did?
Um, oh, anyway, so let me see.
So what Einstein did here,
so we came up here.
So one of his principles there would be
say g equals t and the things he found
there, it, it showed that the
universe was expanding. Um,
so I'll do like that it shows the
universe was expanding. It also, um, uh,
famously described, um, uh,
it explained how mercury wobbled as it
went around the sun. Mercury's orbit.
It wasn't quite what you would think.
The, the curve down there by the sun,
the decay of the,
uh,
of that trampoline or rubber sheet was
greater than Newton winter predicted. Um,
mercury I believe is that so,
so that was under there and he had all
sorts of predictions and they really held
up. It was when he, um, and that
was the simple Gecos teak anyway,
so all that's good. Do you think, okay,
they're technical mistake he gave in,
he shouldn't have given him it sort of
like, they often say in business, uh,
reinforce a victory,
a star of defeat.
But of course when his victory you release
a new product is not doing that well.
Maybe macro penetration and slightly
give it a little bit longer.
It's really good. Bit more, adds a bit
more improvements and tweaks. We have it.
At what point do you stop?
Einstein thought that he had
stopped too soon anyways, from this,
he drew a catastrophic conclusion.
He decided that, um, when,
when never had to listen,
listen to experimental evidence.
If you believe that something clear and
simple had been found right, that the,
the, those, those instructions,
that the divinity or the divine forces
or just the facts of the universe had
made,
he was a kind of a ambiguous on it,
that that would have to be super clear.
Those things you found in the books
in the library, they had to be really,
really simple.
Um,
quantum mechanics started coming in
around this time and Einstein had helped
create quantum mechanics in 1905,
but in the late 1920s,
it was getting even better at the
famous Heisenberg uncertainty principle,
a things like that. Einstein Thought, oh,
this is all very interesting. The, the,
the mathematics is, is, is really good,
and it's a temporary EPA phenomenon. Uh,
our equipment, you can't tell exactly
what's going on. And of course,
probability is very useful. His
early work on, on, on the lasers,
whereas exactly what, probably
our probabilities of a,
of electron transitions.
He said, that's fine. Heisenberg, and
at one point was so excited. Einstein,
he went up, he visited him in Berlin and
said, Professor Einstein, um, I, I was so,
I loved the way you just
used observational evidence
without trying to wonder
what was happening backstage
when you came up with relativity.
That's what I did in quantum mechanics.
Thank you. Einstein looked at them.
It's not what I meant at all. He said,
I didn't mean anything like that. Uh,
he thought that it was just provisional.
If you didn't know the details, uh,
eventually the details
would be clear and exact.
So Einstein couldn't accept quantum
mechanics and it's evidence came in and
there I became more and more evidence. He
just, he wouldn't, he wouldn't accept it.
Now it turns out he couldn't do it.
Some individuals,
so he was stuck up here. This had
worked really, really well. Voom,
applying for this, applying for
that. Why should you ever change it?
This is wonderful. There's something
here that it didn't apply to.
Well that was temporary member.
He had been burned once with the expensive
of the universe is maybe he would
again, imagine you're pushing a
product and you pull back on a to suit.
A competitor does it and it works
perfectly well. He's, I knew it.
I should've just waited.
I have to ignore everybody's
comments against it and stuff.
There's times to really stick to
your guns. Same thing in math.
Same thing in physics.
You're working on a certain approach.
You don't get the right answer right away.
Oh, I'm nervous. I have to jump back.
Now. Sometimes you have to stick. The
question is how long, how long? Um, uh,
some people think that, well,
Einstein faded in his forties,
because in your forties, your brain isn't
as nimble as it it was at other times.
Those of us,
those of you who are anxious about not
being up to the Shaundra level at 19 or
Einstein of 26, um, can re,
uh, remember if you're really,
really quick mental arithmetic that
tends to peak just before age 11.
And if you're good at picking up languages
to get a perfect accent is almost
impossible. After the late teens, early
twenties, something changes in the brain,
you can become fluent, very fluent
in language with a perfect accent,
just gets harder. Um, so the
question is this physical like that.
And the answer curiously is no.
Shandra say car,
that person that I mentioned one day
and I think in, in the early 1980s,
his wife elbowed him in the ribs in
Chicago. She told me this later, um,
and she said, Shondra wake up, it's a
Swedish Academy. You have the Nobel prize.
And he said, without any arrogance,
he said, oh, for what's discovery?
He had about six or seven that were
worthy of the Nobel. Um, so, and he was,
he was doing great work into his sixties,
even into a seven days,
a rally in the 18 hundreds to that.
So there's a number of people to do it.
And in particular,
Einstein's best friend for awhile was
Nell's board and those board, the, uh,
the great, uh, Danish astronomer
who apparently, uh, sorry,
a physicist who apparently had one,
a language which was called bad English.
He could speak bad English
with every accident.
He could speak with a Danish accent.
He could speak with a French accent.
Wherever he went, people found it. I
can't quite get what you say like that.
He would mumble. He was a
wonderful man. And in his sixties,
even in his seventies at his
institute and Copenhagen,
Bright Young Grad students from around
the world wanting to work with them. Um,
Einstein's famous for selling, saying
God does not play dice with the guys.
A guy does not play dice with the
universe. Nell's, Boris said to him once,
Niels Bohr had accepted the
evidence from quantum mechanics.
Once Niels Bohr had looked down at
these new things, these quantum results,
Nelsworth said to him, Einstein, stop
telling God what to do. You know,
looking at the universe,
stop telling them.
So Nell's Bohr had actually moved
over here. This is g equals t,
but more importantly, it's the notion
that everything should be exact.
I'll call it a little right angle.
Everything should be exact
Nell's Bora window over here.
And he had to just slightly
different abstract principle,
which accepted the principles behind
quantum mechanics that this going to be a
certain fundamental probability as
far as you go down to the universe.
It isn't exact. There's going to
be probability and uncertainty.
It isn't terrible.
Things are customed unlimited.
So things as they come to
the macro level are fine.
We can make transistors work very,
very well. But within transistors,
these quantum effects are taking place.
That's what happens.
So Nell's bore had actually managed to
move over here and from here he come with
various clues. So imagine this is
something that doesn't apply there,
but Nell's fourth thing, it applies
very, very well. So he had that,
he was able to move their Einstein
couldn't, uh, the Cavendish lab,
remember I told you the Calvinists
lab fell apart for 20 years.
Find out what's inside the ad
and was a perfect guiding light.
It's the sort of thing, a
nuke. If you've ever been, uh,
watching a video at home and somebody
comes in and say, well, what's going on?
And you give him a little,
you whisper summer or if it's,
if it's 24 saying Jack Bowers almost
about to get the person and the rug is
going to be pulled out from under him
and he'll have to get the person in a
different way that can apply
to any 24 episode ever.
But often you go into a movie and
people will whisper what's going on.
The great thing about these mid level
abstractions is you can whisper to
somebody and they get all the knowledge
of the people have already done the hard
work. How cool is that? Um, I can
whisper to the rules of calculus.
You're smarter than Newton. I can
whisper even in a simple book like this,
a bit of general relativity,
your past, what I would,
Albert Einstein himself did in his
thirties. It's really awesome. Uh,
the Cavendish lab, they whisper to
people who are really bright and physics.
Let's look what's inside the atom.
And immediately they have a good
research proposal. Einstein. Yes. So,
so that's what they did.
But that faded after while,
and then about 15 years later, somebody
else took over. The Cavendish and said,
you know, what would be a really
good middle up mid level abstraction?
Let's use x-ray's to study crystals.
How about crystals are proteins. Yeah,
let's use x rays to study protein
crystals. That was fabulous.
That's how DNA was discovered, right?
It, it crystallizes beautifully.
And the Xray to fractions,
you can work backwards to find the
double helix structure. Hemoglobin.
It was magnificent and they started out
boom with another burst of Nobel prizes,
one after another for about 20
years. Um, what happened next?
You will have to uh, read elsewhere
so when can do it. So, um, anyway,
so I said we would give the examples
of science and then go back to business
about which I'm profoundly not an expert.
Thus we can have a discussion on that.
Or later we can have a discussion
about the curios about Einstein.
You can ask me about his blue parakeet.
Um, but I won't tell you about that now.
Um, so this diagram, which Einstein was
so proud of and I saw you the picture of,
suppose you change it a little bit.
So down here instead of like an expanding
universe, which is noticed or um, uh,
mercury,
which is noticed you have things like
something like there's a big internet,
right?
And then you go up there and say,
what's going to be a really good
way to deal with a big internet?
There were companies like a Yahoo
and stuff that dealt with, I dunno,
they dealt with it in one way.
What if you have the notion up here,
not gene equals t you're not doing tensors
in general relativity, but just say,
I know a really good search system
plus maybe ads to monetize it.
That's going to be a
good way to deal with it.
So these things down here at big internet,
wow,
it applies to it really well and there's
all sorts of other things that applies
to it really, really well. Certain
companies come to mind that were very,
very good at that. Um, so isn't that
neat? So that same logical form,
there's data down there,
there's stuff in the real world.
You make a jump of abstraction,
which isn't going to come from anybody
telling you you have to be exceptional.
Like Rutherford at the cabin dish lab
like Einstein in 1916 to come up to it.
And once you're up into it, also
ordinary people, ordinary skill people,
you put them in that chair
and they can do good stuff.
Captain Kirk is sitting
inside a wonderful chair.
He could not create the
starship enterprise, any of
us sitting in that chair, uh,
including Justin Long from a galaxy quest,
we'll be able to press buttons and shoot
phase and just all sorts of cool stuff.
If you're in the right perch and position,
you have magnificent power, right?
People can come into a company like
this and when this matches that,
they don't have to be the terrific,
uh,
entrepreneurs are geniuses
who come up with this.
They just walk right in there and now
Nell's Bora was able to walk across from
this to that. He was a very flexible
man. The thing is, not everybody does.
Um, so what happens? So this worked
really well. So will a company like this,
and again, this is purely
speculative, will a company
like this last forever? Well,
there's lots of new stuff
coming on down here.
So apps can be sometimes hard to search,
they can be like a walled garden.
There's concerns with privacy.
There's,
there's all sorts of stuff
like that going on. Um, uh,
there's notions of how do you discover
things that haven't already been
categorized in some way.
Just lots of new stuff.
And then there's even stranger things
happening when this company here was
formed,
hipsters in shortage didn't exist.
Shortage was a terrible slum of Brooklyn
was a place where people went if they
got divorced and didn't have any money.
Um,
so there's people with a
slightly different culture,
maybe people who don't like to own cars.
It's no longer cool tone cards.
It isn't part of your definition of
better definition could be, I don't know,
having real life experiences,
live music or genuine fitness or
triatholon something like that.
So new categories or are coming
up apps, blah, blah, blah.
Very occasionally people from
here can change themselves,
but it usually doesn't work.
Remember the Cavendish lab had to
jump over to a different view. Uh,
they couldn't modify looking what's
inside the atom to going there.
They had to have new people came
in rather for died. Max Planck,
the great physicist once said, you never
argue your opponents, you outlive them.
And that's something, um,
so that went over there.
Occasionally a person can make
that move across and move sideways.
So think of again to the extent if search
is going to have limits with some of
these other things over here,
new data bits on here.
Suppose you have something else.
Alphabet, lots of things over here,
quite different.
So there's a big structure like that.
And then from there you can maybe
apply to these things better. Um,
you can apply to those and maybe who
knows? Fresh things will come up.
We don't know.
Now the question is who fills those slots?
Who Fill those slots?
Einstein went to one slide up here
and he could not move across Nell's.
Boris had come come out.
And it's different from what
you've learned. Come on. Yes,
you were really bright at
university doing this. Yes,
you were terrific coming up with these
tools and these tensors come over here
and use this new stuff. You will come
up with great things. And the sadness,
the pathos is that Einstein's mind was up
to it. Uh, as an older man, he said, hmm.
One implication of this quantum mechanics,
if it were to be true,
is quantum entanglement.
That's almost impossible.
His mathematics was exactly right.
This is in 1935, almost a century.
We're actually a century after that.
I think we'll have quite nice
quantum computers, a bit specialized,
but doing well,
he came up with gravitational lensing.
All of this is as an old man.
His brain was terrific,
but he just ventured there
briefly go right back. I
gotta do it this old way. Um,
so very rarely come when move across.
Sometimes you have to
acquire brand new people.
That's why many companies do
well. They have, um, uh, you know,
entire new groups either spinoff
or bright in or something.
I Kasan however magnificent people like
bore and what go up and work across
themselves and steps step by
step into these different things,
which will have those fresh implications.
So I leave you with a question.
Are we Nell's bore or are we Albert
Einstein? And after reading this book,
you'll think, gosh, I used to
think I signed was terrific.
But now I don't want to be
like him at all. Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you very much. Oh, we have
time for questions. So please, uh,
please wait a whole microphone.
So Einstein created
shredding is Captain T. Yes.
So that was basically saying
quantum physics is meticulous way.
Uh, the, uh, uh, uh, I don't want
to ask hands up of people who,
um, who know, who don't know about
Troy niches. Cat. So I'll get,
I'll give a background.
One thing,
one conclusion I would say is
that if a man named Schrodinger,
if you were transformed into a cat,
like you stepped out of
the Internet and well,
I'm a cat and stuff and there's these
strange people around and a man named
shrines here comes up to you, smiling
says, would you like to come home with me?
The answer is no. Under no
circumstances, it's not a good idea.
Schreibman chair was a man that Einstein
really love because of his personal
life. Uh, Shriners Harris' wife used to a
reward him when he had great results. Uh,
she would introduce him to a really nice
twins to go off to the mountain with
and stuff they said about Shriners here
when he came to a Oxford in the 1930s to
arrive at Oxford with one wife is bad
enough to ride with two really accessive
so it's right in your head.
This wild sort of Bohemian life,
which Einstein like that's one reason
Einstein grew his hair like that when he
was young,
he was actually kind of dishy it was
a good looking guy when he was rowing
people said, well, we're gonna do really,
really muscly and stuff when
you bid a sale and Rowan stuff.
But later in bourgeois Berlin and the
1920s, he wanted to fight that to say,
you don't have to line up and be exact.
Like that is his second wife was
incredibly particular Albert.
I don't think that's quite the right way
to hold our forks, that sort of thing.
So he did the hair is
still sort of a resistance.
So he likes Schrodinger and the two
men were really good friends and they
collaborated in the mid 1930s by letter.
Schreibman juror had gotten a
job in a Dublin of all places.
It turns out the guy who ran Ireland,
other time,
devil era and studied mathematics.
So he respected to write in Azure.
And in their correspondence
they came up with this notion.
It turns out very often people come
up with a notion to disprove a theory.
And that notion is really good. And the
reason is we don't like humiliation.
We don't like fear of friend of mine was
a very successful a TV and film writer
and producer and he was really good.
Then when you got a lot of money,
sort of lost his creativity and he tried
all sorts of ways to get his creativity
back, tried working with bright
young people, going into museums,
working in different fields
and none of it worked.
And then his business partner ripped
him off and boy was he motivated.
He started writing terrific stuff.
So Einstein couldn't still dislike the
fact that they've been pushed to the side.
So that brought up his creativity
to real high level. You know,
if you're fired from a company, you
want to show them you're full of energy,
you have to show him.
So he came up with in correspondence
with steroid injuries during his year,
was involved a little bit, um, with this
notion of Heisenberg's cat that, uh, if,
if I,
if there's no way whatsoever to predict
if a certain particle splendid decay
this way or decay that way, um, then the
following curious effect happens and us,
sorry,
suppose you can't predict which way it's
going to go and you will only know it.
It only will, you only know what we
would only happen once you look at it.
Suppose that particles inside a box,
suppose the poor cat is inside the box.
Suppose a large gun,
you see the viciousness of quiet,
often vegetarian physicists. They like,
should the gun have impaling hooks?
You know, should there be a little
trap door underneath it and stuff.
And suppose if the particle decays
and goes this way, nothing happens.
The catwalks around that. And I that if
the particle decays and goes that way,
a big gun, bless it to
smithereens, right? Um,
in a, a standard interpretation
of quantum mechanics.
It not only do you not only
know until you open the box,
which way the particles decayed.
It hasn't,
you can't a Saturday say it hasn't
happened. Um, it's ambiguous until,
uh, until you opened it and looked at
the actually observation helps create it.
Einstein thought that was insane,
but yet a lot of evidence, uh, again,
I'm being a metaphorical about it. A lot
of evidence backed it up. The question,
of course, is Einstein
said, well, in that case,
is the cat alive or dead
before you open the box? Right?
We don't know which way the particle went
and if the trigger was pulled or not.
So the cat alive or dead and clearly
it can't be in a super position of two
states, half dead and half
alive. On the other hand,
if any of you have ever taken the
northern line in London at about 8:00 AM,
you understand many people can be
in that superposition of two states,
half dead and half alive.
So that was a story.
And they came up with that notion to
sort of disprove quantum mechanics.
And people like Nell's board, other
bright young people working with him.
Thought good point. Good point. Yup.
There's a superposition of states until
the observation takes place and that has
certain consequences.
And Lo and behold,
those consequences were used by John
Bardeen who was working at a Princeton at
the time to develop it. True trends
transistor. It's actually true.
How curious is that?
Einstein wouldn't step sideways to accept
it because he had been so comfortable
in their previous position. I have
a, a little addendum to the answer,
but I'm going to stop giving really long
answers. If there's time I'll give it,
just remind me about the, of the
playing card problem. Uh, and uh, but I,
I'd like to have some
more questions first.
Yeah.
So the question is how much of it was
maybe not necessarily religious but just
came from simple aesthetics, beauty rather
than rather than ugliness and crude?
This, the answer is a real
lot. Uh, the, the ads,
the to the two possibilities are related.
Einstein believed in the, uh, um,
the need for architectural simplicity
a little bit because of his religious
views. Uh, Einstein was once interviewed
what he felt about music and he was like,
he was like the guy, you the bless, you
can never please. People said Mendelssohn.
What do you think? What Mendelssohn?
Mendelssohn is wonderful.
The beautiful lyric tunes,
but he lacks a certain architectural.
A whole, what about Shuma? Oh,
Schumacher. I really feel for Schuman,
but it's not incredibly pure and
great. What about Beethoven? Beethoven,
Beethoven, Beethoven. It's terrific.
It's emotional. It's powerful,
but it's a little bit arbitrary.
I thoughts, emotions. Howard,
the one he loved wasn't even back.
He loved Mozart because Mozart is not
just the surprise that the thing with
Mozart is what comes next is unexpected
but plausible. How cool is that?
Unexpected but plausible that that's
what's happening. It's like a really,
really good a thriller,
but often it felt true.
It wasn't just a little game.
It felt,
you feel that a little barrier has been
removed and you're seeing truths of the
universe and bits of Mozart, at least
for Einstein and sometimes for me.
Can I just say as a footnote,
Mozart's clarinet concerto with,
I once listened to when I was in the
south of France and had two recordings for
about a week.
I can never hear that again in my life.
People tell me it's beautiful,
but please don't play it in my presence.
But as for the aesthetics,
that would be it.
And when Einstein was dissatisfied
and unhappy when he was young,
he played the violin and played
really well. But when it was older,
his fingers got a little bit arthritic.
And what he loved was just
noodling away on the piano.
He would noodle for hours and hours
and hours and Berlin and Princeton,
a little bit of Jazz, a little bit of
classical jazz, of all sorts of stuff. Um,
aesthetics meant everything to him because
he felt they were a sign of something
very,
very true.
And
it drove him into isolation.
How sad is that
next?
So, um, I'm things, um, mistakes,
which one would you say would be
one would be his greatest mistake?
We could have prevented a conference
meeting more than of that.
Great question. So out of all the
mistakes, what was, what was the key,
what was the worst,
the most fundamental mistake and many
people think the mistake was modifying the
g equals t equation. Again, that's,
that's just a metaphor modifying and
adding extra terms. But that was,
that was a mistake. But it's mistake that
anybody can make and then fix it. Oh,
actually I was wrong.
And you go back with the same attitude
that it had when he was young that you
would climb up here,
which is beautiful.
But then you would check things
against the consequences.
And if ugly facts really got in the way,
you would have to change this
however beautiful it was going up.
So I think his mistake wasn't the
scientific mistake about the lambda.
The extra term anybody could have
done that. The mistake was, was was,
was diving in and saying it
was a psychological mistake.
I've been burned once.
I'm never going to be burned
again. Right. Tony Blair had a,
a possibility early in his
tenure as prime minister to, uh,
help NATO forces go into a Costco. And
a lot of people said, don't do that.
It's imperialism, it's not going to
work. It's really messy on the ground.
He ignored them. He went into Costco and
on the whole it worked quite well. Um,
a few years later, he wanted to go into
Iraq. People said, don't go into Iraq.
You're going to mess things up.
You're taking, it's a hornet's nest.
Everything will get worse.
And he said, Ma, they said
that before. And I was right.
I stuck to my guns. I'm going to
stick to my guns gun. And in fact,
he was wrong the second time. So that was
Einstein's problem. The second mistake.
Now it happens a lot to people who are
at the top level because they were so
successful before.
If I have like a plausible hypothesis
and then it's proven wrong,
and then it's later proven right, that's
nice. But it's just a plus by hypothesis.
But if I come up with general relativity,
wow. And that's finally, you know,
proven right? Again, I'm really not cocky,
but I'm very confident in my beliefs.
I feel, even if I don't feel
I'm speaking for myself,
I feel I've been able to find
something true about the universe.
The people who hustled really,
really hard to get to the, uh,
to get to the top usually have one stick,
one special approach that really,
really works. Um, and they
have to push hard to get it.
And it's often a magical approach.
It almost never happens twice.
A Lester Thoreau,
the,
the guy at MIT who clearly has been
described as less than thorough,
which is mean pointed out that hardly
anybody who creates a company creates two
different companies ever. Occasionally
there's people to do it at that idea.
Unfortunately,
I came to me as a teenager,
I read his book and it bothered me
so much that the first time I had a
bestseller, I thought, yeah, well,
but I had a second one 10 years later and
I said, yes, Lester. Yes, we can do it.
We can do a separate thing. First
time could be luck. Second time. Okay,
when knows how to do this stuff.
Einstein specifically that you've not
only write a whole book about them,
but wrote a second book.
I'm amazed. I'm amazed at what human
beings could do. Um, and also, uh,
ordinary human beings.
I grew up in a ordinary Jewish
family in Chicago after World War II,
and many people in the neighborhood
would have a picture of Einstein up on
refrigerator or an encyclopedia about
when they're thinking of Einstein.
And I thought, this is a noble and good
man. I feel some connection with him,
but I had no idea what he did. I had
no idea. Some people, some people,
I don't know if they invent a computer
or they invent a car or a particular
device or an airplane, it's beautiful.
But when I was a little child,
I didn't know what Einstein Hinton at
university. I learned about it and I was,
I was amazed. It was sort of like
listening to Mozart for the first time,
or in my case, Mozart,
especially the clarinet concerto,
but like good blues or
something. You listen to it
and feels this is really true.
Sort of like on a really good date.
On a mediocre date,
you tell you you're cute stories,
they tilt their cute stories,
but on a really good date,
you're just connected there.
You're just directly connected. There's
no artifice from top to bottom and stuff.
So when I was learning about
Einstein, I thought, wow,
he cuts through in the university.
So what's really there?
This notion of geometry inducing,
the sensation of force, uh,
as with,
you know,
people going to the North Pole and
feeling they're pulled together or with
gravity coming their way.
That's incredible.
So I really wanted to share it and they
didn't want it to find out how did he do
it? I mean, what sort of man
was he? What was his background?
One thing that helps in as an a
background like that is to be not a total
outsider. If you're a total outsider,
you don't have enough education,
but not to be a total insight or either.
It helps to be sort of on the edge.
Moderate discrimination works really,
really well in a science and in business,
very much several discrimination.
They don't give you a chance.
Monitor discrimination,
you know, two things. Hey,
you have to work a little bit harder.
And B,
what you've learned before about
the system isn't necessarily true.
Suppose somebody grows up, uh,
saying an extremely religious,
a fundamentalist religious view.
As a kid,
they're taught to say that the world is
based on turtles and it's turtles all
the way down. They go to university and
the people there who teach astronomy say,
that's nonsense.
It's not like that at all.
Here I'm going to teach you
the later latest results.
This is what we know is totally true. The
person might think maybe, but maybe not.
Well, my mother taught me was, was
wrong. Maybe what I learned from you,
maybe that not necessarily as
wrong as that previous thing,
but I'll be a little bit cynical.
Compare that to somebody who was, hey,
a professor's kid. They grew up
learning the latest results. You know,
on a simplified version of these nice
books you buy for your kids when you feel
guilty and you're watching Jack Bauer
saved the day again, um, or, um,
and then when they go to university
and it's more of the same,
they have no reason to be really,
really critical.
So Einstein was enough of
an outsider to be critical,
but not so much that he was,
um, uh, that he had no training.
Right.
Hold on to this skepticism about when I,
I'm assuming the experimental
results like experiments. Yeah.
So how did he hold onto
a skepticism when one,
I suppose he held up to it?
Well, a couple of reasons. One,
he had seen that large groups
of people can be wrong.
All the astronomers in the world,
everybody,
whether they were very theoretical,
are very practical.
They all were persuaded that the universe
was static for 10 years or eight years
and stuff. And it's like, Ooh, they
had been wrong. They'd been rung once.
What if they had been wrong for 20 or
30 years? They were certain results.
The ability to measure
things in the university.
It was very difficult to measure.
Absolute distances is hard.
We know that if we know the absolute
brightness of a car headlight at a certain
distance,
what we perceive of it is,
is going to be high or low and then the
intensity and then we can work out from
its absolute magnitude,
uh, how far away it is.
So it took a long time until astronomers,
it was a woman named Henrietta
[inaudible] in Boston who found out,
who found out,
who managed to find a way of measuring
the distance to the nearest I galaxies.
And, uh, that allowed us to get a proper,
a proper yardstick for the universe.
So suppose Henry had 11 hadn't done
that. 50 years may have passed. Einstein.
Einstein knew he was lucky.
It only was 10 years.
So it could have been past his death
passed his whole lifetime that people
thought the universe was static. And Lo
and behold, it was not static, you know,
the greatest authorities. So that
was one. The other thing is, uh,
in the 1920s and thirties,
he saw an entire country's go mad as
countries go mad and nuts at, uh, uh,
in 1933, uh, uh, many books were
burned in Germany, in public,
including in the greatest university
town everywhere in the world.
Then it was Kirsten again. It'd
be like, could you imagine if it,
if it Cambridge and MIT
and all those places,
they start burning books with enthusiasm
from the students and Einstein's books
for some of those that was there were
burned. It was non area and physics.
It was terrible. So he knew, hey,
entire organizations can go nuts.
I just have to be quiet and wait it out.
But he was wrong.
Thank you.
[inaudible].